that's a good way really to start
because but all of the
heaviness of last night's interview and
the seriousness and all the emotion
to say there was some great news that
she's pregnant with a baby girl yeah
i'm gonna be a girl dad yes i was gonna
say though that's where the good news
ended for the royal family
whatever they thought it was going to be
it felt like it was worse well that's
the thing
tony i don't know what people thought
but nobody was expecting that
nobody was expecting that here's another
word to add to the list of how you
described last night we'll begin with
their
explosive the explosive interview
touched on so many issues including race
mental health and what appears to be a
deep rift in the royal family
prince harry and megan were candid quite
candid and emotional as they spoke with
oprah
their first major interview together
since stepping down from royal duties
but in order to tell what they say is a
real story the couple also had to
address what they call is a false
reporting of tabloid newspapers
starting with a widely reported rumor
about megan that she made her future
sister-in-law
kate middleton cry that was a week of
harry and megan's wedding
you say the narrative with kate it
didn't happen so specifically
did you make kate cry no
so where did that come from
was there a situation where she might
have cried or she could have cried
no the reverse happened you knew all
along
and people around you knew that that
wasn't true everyone in the institution
knew it wasn't so why didn't somebody
just say that it's a good question
speaking to oprah the duchess of sussex
described a world that left her isolated
and feeling trapped
i remember so often people within the
firm would say
well you can't do this because it'll
look like that you can't so even
can i go and have lunch with my friends
no no you're oversaturated you're
everywhere
and i said i've left the house twice in
four months
i'm everywhere but i am nowhere
and from that standpoint i continued to
say to people
i know there's an obsession with how
things look but has anyone talked about
how it
feels because right now i could not feel
lonelier
loneliness along with an onslaught of
negative headlines at the palace would
not refute
and that meghan markle insists were
false led to thoughts of suicide
i just didn't i just didn't want to be
alive anymore
and that was a very clear
and real and frightening
constant thought
and i remember i remember how he just
cradled me and i was
i went to the institution and i said
that i needed to go somewhere to get
help and i was told that i couldn't that
it wouldn't be good for the institution
i share this because
there are so many people who
are afraid to voice that they need help
and i know
personally how hard it is to not just
voice it but when you voice it to be
told
no but we had to go to this event and i
remember him saying i don't think you
can go and i said i can't be left alone
because you were afraid of what you
might do to yourself
and we went and that's so sorry to hear
that
the couple also shared with oprah that
when they were expecting their son
archie
the palace brought up his title and
security detail
those months when i was pregnant all
around this same time
so we have in tandem the conversation of
he won't be
given security he's not going to be
given a title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what and
who who is having that conversation
with you
what so um
there is a conversation hold up hold up
there are separate differences there are
several conversations there's a
conversation
with you with harry about
how dark your baby is going to be
potentially and what that would mean or
look like
that was relayed to me from harry oprah
asked prince harry about that discussion
when he
joined the interview what was that
conversation
that conversation i'm never going to
share
um but at the time at the time it was
awkward i was a bit shocked
um can you can you tell us what the
question was no
i'm not comfortable with sharing that
they say it was that lack of support
that ultimately led them to step away
from royal life
do you think you would have left or ever
stepped back
were it not for megan
hmm no the answer to your question is no
i would not have i wouldn't have i
wouldn't have been able to
because i myself was trapped please
explain how you
prince harry raised in a palace in a
life of privilege
literally a prince how you were trapped
trapped within the system
like the rest of my family are my father
and my brother
they are trapped they don't get to leave
and i have huge compassion for that
harry also revealed his family cut him
off financially
last year but i've got what my mum left
me
and without that we would not have been
able to do this
okay so you know touching back on what
you asking what my mum would think of
this
i think she saw it coming and i
certainly felt her presence throughout
this whole process
so much unpacked there if you but let's
start with this if you or someone you
know
is seeking mental health resources you
can call the national alliance on mental
illness
there's a helpline at 1-800-950-6264
i'll say it again
1-800-950-6264 in a real crisis
text nami that's n-a-m-i to 7-4-1-7-4-1
but let's go back to megan for just a
second there were so many revelations
there and i think
we should add the word brave that she
said number one you could tell oprah was
certainly caught off guard when she
talked about
having suicidal thoughts that to me was
also very new and i
i got very choked up just listening to
her explain
how difficult it is to seek help and
then to be told no no no there's nothing
we can do i thought it was brave of her
to share that i thought it was
interesting at that moment too that she
kept referring
to the monarchy as the institution yeah
yeah
which makes it sound impenetrable and it
appears
in many ways it was and to help people
understand how it was i thought it was
remarkable that she acknowledged she had
to hand over her passport and her ideas
she became part of the family so when
they say trapped you're
trapped think about that there's a part
uh i don't know if it was on the air
last night but even on her birth
on archie's birth certificate it doesn't
even say her name yeah you know it says
her met her royal highness or something
like that where she talks about her
identity being stripped away
it was i think it was a real insight as
to how
it operates and what they were both
dealing with yeah